Now you'll learn how to run queries to find
conferences that were created by a specific user. Remember that
each conference has an ancestor, and that the ancestor
is the profile entity of the user who created it.
Here's how you creat a query to get all
the entities that have a particular ancestor. You just add
the ancestor function to the end of the query
creation. You need to specify the key of the parent.
That is the key of the ancestor whose descendants
you want to query for. This kind of query is
called an ancestor query, but you could also think
of it as a descendant query that is because it
gets all the descendants of a particular entity. So
conferences for example. You can get all the conferences that
were created by a certain user. So go ahead and
add a new function in ConferenceAPI called getConfrencesCreated that returns
conferences created by the logged in user. So
again, the HTTP method is going to be post. And
this time, the user must be logged in because
you're trying to get the conferences created by the
logged in user and define the function to
return all the conferences that the user created. And
again test on localhost before you deploy to app
spot and run your query on local host first,
because if you deploy direct to app spot the
first, and then try to run the query for the
first time, you're going to find it doesn't work. So
after you've defined and tested your get conferences created method
take a look at the code and come and answer
this quiz. What I want you to do is figure
out which is the right code here to complete this
statement to get all the conferences created by the user.